[Music]
Dayton part two
go here we go here we go tell you guys
I'm taking a dab all right let's do it
this is my younger brother out there
see I don't know he must have moved to
Seattle
and he ignores by the way Seattle home
of Frazier
I I want to point out that we said this
yesterday but I want to point it out
again he doesn't come home a lot anymore
because his home is in Seattle
yes
[Music]
living here beating me
you know what we'll do that way he knows
what happens in your house
I'll just send your I'll just send your
younger brother a link to our Channel
there you go that way you don't have to
worry about gas yeah he'll get it
remember when this family was reaching
out to us at the beginning of this be
like he's [ __ ] terrible this guy
[ __ ] sucks guys don't Parts it's so
funny it's a full family hates him
wouldn't you hate him too though Jesus
Christ imagine being stuck in a house
with this guy
reply with the only occasion I replied
I made to him
even hard things even reply to messages
or he would stop replying after one
reply
because I guarantee you you weren't
messaging him
like a normal human and being like hey
bro long time no talk how you been
instead he kept messaging messaging him
like he beat me again Sherman keeps
beating me
and his friend your brother probably
texted you back like Sherman's been dead
now for like [ __ ] three years bro
what are you doing
what you mean my sleep now and my dreams
Freddy Krueger
good I hope I hope his brother did
become Freddy Krueger and I hope he
sucks Dayton into the [ __ ] bed like
Johnny Depp
hey I'm gonna message the guy that gets
me the uh gets me these
and I'm gonna have him give me his
younger brother's Facebook I'm gonna
have a little talk with him oh boy
transfer
is so bad
but here's the thing buddy maybe it's
not transphobia did you ever think that
maybe it's just you that they don't like
right like if I meet a trans person
that's cool I'll be like hey you're
pretty cool whatever
me to trans person I don't like that
doesn't mean I hate trans people
they just hate you Dayton yeah I know
but remember since we talked to trans
people we've talked about it in this
town
Cade
paradoxo there he is hi buddy stupid man
hi buddy
there's an enabler in mindset
I can't hear you as I pray for the
person that's families
he sucks
in his life
what what are we doing today
for everything
and my younger brother you know he's a
trendy Seattle person now he's moving
yeah the trendy city of
Seattle wait weren't you like having
Daydreams about like opening up
boutiques and hanging with Christina
Ricci I mean
across the country
and to him that gives an excuse to
ignore anything that's happening
in his you know in his house all right
his older brother's beating the [ __ ] off
a trans person bro he died oh he's not
there anymore
won't
Let It Go
I honestly didn't know how he was gonna
function when he lost this villain in
his life but he just goes on as if he's
still around
because he has nothing else
[Music]
all right come on Peanut Butter ears
what's going on Peanut Butter ears
God that's so disgusting come on shaking
flake what what are we doing shaking
flake flake
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
seven years of a skinhead beating me in
this house
doing it again I mean this was his
bedroom in here bro leave his bedroom
alone it was dead speeding was I think
like dude the person left the most empty
for the loss of [ __ ] time of his
mother is him I know it's very funny
it's weird man lost his [ __ ] because
he lost his super villain origin story
guy his his parents have been like Joker
without Batman wasn't there wasn't there
a plot where Batman died and Joker was
like [ __ ] out of his mind yes it was
a Dark Knight Returns The Dark Knight
Returns when Batman quit Joker just to
stop talking he just stopped talking he
just he couldn't he couldn't do anything
anymore and that's what happened with
him he broke him he [ __ ] broke he's
second time the about half a year later
maybe I think it was like happier later
and
you know what all it was too his brother
was the only person that ever just
looked at him and said no Dayton shut up
shut up
and maybe the reason the parents were
okay with Sherman moving it was because
he protected them from me from you oh
absolutely pretty much once a year just
anytime I interacted with him basically
completely only interacted with him once
so wait so he got beat up all the time
but no no forget I know you're hearing
that but this the better part of that is
but he only beat you once a year
nonsensical
belligerent Pig
and he was living here a few years
before Donald Trump was even in office
what does that have to do with anything
Trump
crazy Nazi skinhead before that point
and he was pro-trump before Trump and
then yeah she saw all the trumps and
words of her skinheads turns out just
like so was the entire hip-hop industry
and [ __ ] Millions
so he kept beating me out of some sense
of Glory where did he beat you against
trans people he hurt his hand when
Dayton hit him over the head with a wine
glass
it's [ __ ] disgusting my younger
brother he ignored all the Outreach I
made occasionally he would reply back
Dean you have to look at the comments
that we do on the eclipse of these
things most people want to hit you men
and women gay and straight do you know
hold on
hold on we should be there we're back
we're back we're back at the [ __ ]
Dayton is Dayton is the great unifier
that Biden said he was going to be
that's a really good point you know what
I mean everyone's United because
everyone wants to beat your ass you're
like that you like the hysterical woman
on that plane an airplane and there's
just a lion all the way down the plane
of people with different weapons just
getting ready to hit you with them but
I've we've had people in the in the
eclipse in the clips like of Dayton
Clemson I'm sure you've seen them too
much people like I'm I'm super gay and I
hate this guy I want to beat him up like
there's gay people that want that house
yeah it's super weird
it was something I would imply there
it's not so bad also keep this in mind
Dayton is not gay okay
he says that he's trans
but he still likes women
because he had experienced violence from
him as well
and so it was no big deal it's like
that's [ __ ] disgusting first of all
I'm nowhere near their sides by the way
do you know what I was thinking about
the other day Mercedes there's probably
people that are that are tuning in like
new people on Rumble specifically tuning
in and like seeing this video and going
like are these guys gonna even
acknowledge the way he's dressed like a
woman and it's like I keep forgetting
that for uh we're used to this like
we're yeah we're deep down this this to
us
the wearing a dress thing is like the
least weird thing about the guy you know
the guy is is just transcended
any sort of Locale we've ever covered we
got to remember that we're like you know
the the old-timers we've been in Vietnam
for a long time yeah exactly and some of
the people on Rumble that are watching
our show for the first time are the guys
that just got to Vietnam and are like
damn are the mosquitoes always this bad
and you're we're just rolling our eyes
the two they're between the two of them
it's like what there's like
three four inches of you know height
difference
and they're both over six feet tall they
were both like six feet are over and
like you know that's ridiculous neither
of them are you know physically thin
actually I mean I've never trained to be
a boxer in my life and my skinhead
brother trained to be a boxer
okay they didn't succeed so he beat me
instead I mean what have you succeeded
at at least he tried something can I be
honest with you dating though let's say
your brother trained at boxing and then
he kept beating you up all the time
doesn't that technically count as you
training and boxing oh that's right
you've been trained
I mean is it training at boxing
basically just practicing fighting with
a guy who's better than you at boxing
yeah
get away in the south
just keep it on right here it's [ __ ]
messed up because my younger brother
hasn't been in town
I think a year and a half or something
um
and I think pretty much the last time
before that yeah because then you have
to go back to Dayton on purpose
it's a longer span of time before he was
in town and
the only time they're all going on
vacation and the only time I have
afforded to go on vacation in the past
several years was back in 2016 because
they have jobs and they have an income
and they could afford to go and they're
trying to get away from you and and
Dayton I have a feeling that if you
weren't just such a [ __ ] horrendous
person to be around they'd probably take
you yeah good point it'd probably take
you along on vacation but you just stick
the vacations are from you
and I couldn't even I couldn't afford to
buy my own plane ticket
my so my terrible [ __ ] messed up
parents are good enough to actually buy
the plane ticket right
he's doing it again
the parents that he makes Secret videos
of on YouTube and accused him of
murdering their brother yesterday with
covid
is now
upset that they're not of the kindness
of Their Own Heart even though let them
live there buy them food even though
they pay all his bills
they're not giving them a vacation which
is the biggest travesty if you think
about it yeah his parents are really
[ __ ] awful people
but I could bear I had to spend my very
flimsy savings remember when he was
remember when he was basically in the
last video when he was basically like
low-key trying to throw them under the
bus for like tax of fraud yeah yeah yeah
getting him off the books yep you know
the money that it costs to do anything
of this fan of the 10 days or so or
something so he's mad about not being
able to afford a vacation hey guys why
don't you fill the rumble people in what
does he do for a living
yeah a vacation from what okay that's a
really good point guys you're right
forget the fact that he's arguing about
a vacation I need a vacation for my
vacation you can't go to the beach
because you would [ __ ] fry because
you don't have skin on you where where
would you consider vacation Transylvania
do you want to sleep in a car okay well
probably Dr Phil Studio do you want to
go smell Owen Benjamin's fingers I don't
what do you want here
Amy
is that
or so
a week and a half maybe of um
spending time Seattle with my younger
brother back in 2016. is the only time I
could afford a vacation and I couldn't
even afford the plane ticket I had a uh
and I spent hundreds of dollars uh of my
money that I earned below working below
minimum wage oh there we go you know the
hardest thing for me to do because we
get these videos and they're not public
they're unlisted
is not saying something I'm not I never
will because I'm never going to stop the
the faucet but you know how bad I just
want to just type something like you're
gonna [ __ ] job you [ __ ] loser yeah
I know I would never obviously because
this is too good you know minimum wage
income for my parents who refused to pay
me anything decent to stay in age
because they're both they were both born
in the 1940s yes I think they don't have
to pay you though you're you're they're
doing a this is what I love about him
man you're doing you're getting a favor
done for you in the first place
and then the favor becomes a demand
this is why you don't feed like they
said signs and say don't feed the Bears
at like state parks and [ __ ]
it was believed in like the the
pre-inflation prices of when they were
yeah oh good we're gonna get an
economics lesson now from a guy who
never left his house who makes a hundred
dollars for not folding laundry probably
be normal back in the 1970s or 80s or
something I don't know guys be quiet I
want to learn the health burrito
economics
elf burrito baby it's ridiculously low
income and I embodied
[ __ ] Murray rothbard over here I'm
sorry they call it fickle down it's
pickle down economics
this all bleeds head to toe on my body
and now I'm taking turmeric for it which
helps a little bit doesn't help enough
pretty much that it started helping a
lot now it's helping moderately anyway
would be a lot worse if I wasn't taking
it because it'd be bleeding constantly
now it's just red and patchy well maybe
stop [ __ ] playing stop [ __ ] with
it very red right now from the weather
hey we'll never know his struggle as a
psoriasis gender male no listen to me
okay that's me what you're you're done
let me explain something done
you're dead to me after that one right
it's just gender male is that what sis
is short for yes it's psoriasis I'm
psoriasisgendered
um the the thing with him is you're
fired from my life the thing is with
with him this [ __ ] guy with with
Dayton is
he he's trying to be this trans thing
but overall the thing that seeps through
him is that he's always going to be
autistic and and and you see that and
you right like that's the overwhelming
power he already said trans well that's
true
obviously I mean like a good percentage
of them are just autistic people being
taken advantage of oh yeah
in September
it makes it really
bad like on my skin like my skin turns
very that's why Blair white likes
trained so much
oh that was the wrong kind of train that
was a different train [ __ ]
[ __ ] red and some parts of my skin gets
like purplish red tell me
that's the band Train oh why is it just
gets randomly like it's so messed up
that it's like
I don't know why but probably something
hey hey Royce I've got something you
don't know
in this house
it's sorry for me to cut you off it just
popped to my head
hey there he is yeah there's little baby
Dayton
tell me if he used the Box
[Laughter]
tell me does he beat you in this house
you told me
drops of psoriasis is the name of the
song yes
I I somehow didn't have to get an
emergency room but I remember being such
a bad beating the way it made me feel
sore that it was even worse than the
previous time that I went to the
emergency room for a beating every
single beating got worse and worse hey
flaky sister I Don't Wanna Miss a single
video you make
foreign
it's crazy and
I fled the house after that beating for
he fled the house he fled in the middle
of the night like the Hebrews few months
uh stayed at a friend's place like the
Hebrews I I kept working here it's very
not I kept coming to the house once a
week and working or whatever once or
twice a week to make sure that the house
was clean because these people to do
your laundry so your mom would do your
laundry yeah exactly so your mommy would
do your laundry
and that's pretty much that video after
that it just goes into undercover mode
again
so we don't ever get to see the brother
huh I mean I have I mean I haven't seen
him yet so yeah I don't think so
[ __ ]